welcome welcome to your mom's house
[Music]
Jean really big episode today a lot to
get into I'm just overwhelmed with
excitement that that it's about to go
down you know what I mean yeah you know
I'm saying oh you feel me oh don't talk
about yeah all right let's get into this
right here
it's the lambo episode it's gonna be a
good one guys let's get into it
fuck good okay if you're a hot black guy
you want to fuck me at 2395 if you want
to move in you come move in but you
gotta fuck me I mean I need to be fucked
a lot man get ripped free food free
wrench and everything else man it has a
deal man
Tom Segura Christina
[Music]
man good stuff right yeah men are the
absolute biggest of the pigs it's really
crazy the world is full of this and it's
the guy's only criterion is that the the
guy be black yeah like not even like red
you get Lisa Nike off me
yeah there you go but you'd be a psycho
yeah you're gonna have all kinds of
diseases he's like I don't care just as
long as you gotta fuck me yep black and
you gotta be willing to to fuck me I
mean you think there would be more of a
filter that's it white guys who love the
fucking fuck good yeah if you're a hot
black guy you want to fuck me at 2395
Jesus grace you gotta fuck thee I mean I
need to be fucked a lot man get ripped
free food free wrench and everything
else man you have a deal man
there's part of it that is part of it as
a woman make you realize just how how
much the men's sexual drive can just
hold them hostage in some ways yeah like
I see this as a guy I'm like no worries
that right now yeah I no worries that
right now I don't I don't fathom it like
I don't I personally and I'm sure there
are women out there he's just in a bad
place he shouldn't have posted this you
know Justin if I just push through yeah
I just released the demons get through
it man I just don't I don't know I've
never been here as a woman like this
desperate for prove that you know yeah I
most most the time I don't think we see
a lot of women with these types of
videos then from jail homeless or for
the thug gonna come move in a Franklin
only to man your Frankie moving renting
at least a nut cake
fuck me piss somebody beat me at home
you know you see me when I come over
today and try it out try it out man just
try it out and he gave out his address
yeah he's like come find me he said
homeless Jesus
but as long as you're black and homeless
and out of prison and you can bring your
friend your friend can watch if you want
to try it out today all right it's like
it's like a free trial what's the
problem sealed and tried out looks like
a piss let me try it out she defied only
us fuck man I'm looking for hardcore
guys I mean it want to do it and I want
to deliver it I'm a hot pot white trash
come dump let's fuck
Wow huh where is he where is he in mind
like where is that I mean blue band cut
out the address for the dark very
thoughtful I mean that's really crazy
I mean emotionally where is this guy oh
yeah he's worse off than I thought and
actually I I think this is uh this is
dipping into drugs territory I don't
think he just backed up I think he's uh
I think he's fueled by 16 benadryl yes
he might be on the benadryl take 10 20
bro surprised that guy you wanna get
horny God maybe this guy took too many
benadryl and there's no one no one to
help him look if you want to move in you
come move in sake
how much is that by the way there's a
lot of people think it would take this
guy no I think it's a good deal actually
it's a great deal if you are homeless
and black it's a really good deal if you
meet those two criteria that's yeah
that's all he's asking he didn't even
say like big day said out of jail yeah
his standards are incredibly low but he
didn't even say you know drug free
disease free big dick ready to fuck just
relax but here's the thing you can't
just be black you also got to be down to
fuck this guy a lot a lot but what is a
lot do you think see that's the thing
that's a subjective term but I think he
means it I don't think a lot means yeah
a lot you know today tomorrow I was like
no no I think this guy means like
breakfast lunch and dinner
what's his rent he wants his food
I also think he'd get tired of you
though I think he's you know he's the
kind of guy that needs a new piece I
think so what do you think his
apartments like probably are super nice
huh why do you think it's so nice I mean
he seems like he takes care of himself
and he's like takes guy that Mustang
that's why I'm saying like he likes his
look to be fresh food or something
outside of his mouth you know I'm
looking for hardcore guys that mustache
is insane to God we're like piss on me
daddy eats me yeah he's there's
definitely a different place than I
thought he was in I mean I understood
you know I mean I have to know that
exists too but I thought he was just
like I'm fuckin fired up yeah he's just
like take out all that rage on me if you
want if you might build and try it out
Jesus he wants to be abused this guy try
it all out I and my bills and tried out
looks like a piss let me try it out it's
he replied only us fuck man I'm looking
for hardcore guys I mean it want to do
it and I want to deliver it from a hot
fall by trash come dump let's fuck where
is he posting this I don't know
is this a Craigslist video add those
eyes all the eyes are terrifying yeah
man
I feel like as though to you know if
you're putting an offer like that out
into the world you might want to record
yourself in a more flattering light yeah
maybe turn the light on maybe sit up
he's laying back camera over oh yeah
like maybe make yourself look more
attractive yeah like some people know
how to look attractive on camera yeah
you know I mean it's like lighting
[Applause]
not the dog not the dog sniff King a
stripper party on his dog now that's the
thing
this is either animal abuse or the dog
loves it that's the thing yeah that's
what I wanted to discuss we don't know
we don't know first of all the dog
doesn't know that his dad is a celebrity
so huge star huge star vic talent i will
say that he kept a healthy distance
mother um - like he wasn't like sitting
on him right it wasn't abusive and he
gave him a nice pet yeah that's the king
right there yeah see this this falls
into nasty or not it's exactly right
yeah do you think it's a nasty or not
well I mean it depends on the dog
because we've got two dogs yeah one dog
loves the farts yeah one dog does not
one dog you fart in his area and he gets
up and he walks away one dogs heaven is
another dogs hell yeah now if you're
King a strippers dog you got to find
this to be heaven because yeah he farts
24/7 true there's a guy that can find ya
pretty excited the dog doesn't seem
bothered by the fart so I'm gonna go
with not nasty yeah this ain't saying
that nasty I don't think it's too nasty
now is this an old video because he
looks thinner here I'm thinking this
might be before he got real large he
really blew up recently what else it
says there's something else here let's
see the dog didn't but he did turn his
head slightly away
what's nastier when King a stripper
farts on his food and then eats it or
how many farts on near this dog it's the
food the food is really gross it's nasty
this is this is only nasty if you think
farts are nasty but he's not like a
pound he's abusing the dog dogs
comfortable dog just moved its head
and he didn't like you know write likes
like sit on he's farting in his area
I think it's fine this incorporates two
of my favorite things doggies and King
ass Ripper yeah this is like the most
perfect video ever made the dog doesn't
like it he will get up and leave and
this would have a different feeling if
he was like holding the dog there and
that's different yeah yeah he's just
farting near the dog and the dog made a
choice to leave when it was okay okay
with thinking a stripper didn't insist
that the dog stay for the part so it
wasn't abuse the dog again
he's a few feet above its head you know
the animal activists are just all lit up
right now well I know about him I
probably get some emails the house how
dare you fire my dogs we're gonna skip
all over him just say yeah fire on a
dog's yeah you farted on on both of our
dogs heads several times farted on their
heads - in bed they lay right there
looking at you how where is this by the
way why is farting on a dog it's so
funny to me I don't know
that's one of my life's Joy's you know
you know how I was talking about the
difference between relief and joy I
would say farting on a dog's head
qualifies as joy that's one of the few
things that really lifts me up out of
the doldrums you know what I mean yeah
farting just farting is just great in
general so I want to talk about the
Lambo prank oh my god so fun and the
actual the video is gone then what's
taking it down but so well just one of
these things I'll explain so for people
that don't know I mean most you know
there are fans of our show that we've
been doing a sober October and October
2014 and it included being sober for the
month not drinking or taking drugs
smoking weed and for you that's really
not a challenge not that big of a
challenge
and also 15 90-minute hot yoga classes
have you farted in any of those classes
the closest I came was today by far so
today I finished number 15
congratulations you're done with sober
October how do you feel recording this
on the 26 so I saw a few days this true
I feel like it's you know I'm glad to be
done it was an interesting test in
discipline which I'm a fan of I like
challenges I like being challenged
things I responded well to the weight
loss challenge
I like being challenged here it's fun
it's fun I think it's healthy for people
in general to hear something like hey
like just to test your discipline every
once in a while in other words sure 24/7
all the time no I mean it's not for me
but I think if you have the opportunity
to just test yourself I think you learn
things about yourself and you learn one
of the things you learn is that you're
capable probably of more than you think
you know yeah which is a it's a good
thing to learn about usually I can't say
I guess I was today I would thought
about you saying that because you said
that to me earlier
yeah weak and I was thinking about it
and I was like I feel like everyday life
is is that challenge yeah like I I'm so
anxious and so I'm just a is a battle to
just to just be normal is that I you
know I mean I feel like every day is an
exercise and discipline is that normal
is that hello no no maybe that's why I
don't like challenges maybe I don't know
I mean I think what I mean though I know
what you have you're saying and I know
exactly what you mean but what I'm
talking about is more in terms of
somebody like when it's like hey this is
hard I don't want to do that thing you
know like go on a run let's say if
you're a runner you're a runner but
let's say you're not and somebody says
can you go run a mile and you're like oh
I hate doing that but I mean like I'm
physically capable of doing I just hate
doing it right and it's like get up and
do that five times this week fuck I
don't want to do and you think of all
the reasons that it sucks but then you
go
I'm gonna do that thing I know the thing
that I'm capable of doing but it's
difficult to do and I'm gonna do it the
whole time whatever the plan is that
kind of stick sticking to it
yeah that kind of challenge exercise and
discipline yeah it could be something it
says have to be physical it could be
like writing if you're like yes yeah sit
down at a computer write an hour a day
or whatever sure I feel like I don't
want to do that yeah yeah I know you
don't want to do it but can you do it I
think at the end of that challenge if
let's say if it was writing you'd be oh
wow this was greatly benefited right
because you force yourself to do
something and then it and then you the
rewards from that are pretty good well
yeah I guess you could say Pilates and
and dieting for me was my discipline
thing absolutely I'd actually really
turned my life around mentally because
then you go oh I can do this like I'm
not some schmuck that's just a slave to
their their whims you know yeah I have
no yeah I guess so I guess
self-discipline that's a good thing well
this is um so we'll be doing this
challenge and we poke fun at each other
especially Ari Bert and I we used to
little jabs at each other when we make
videos I mean Airy yeah Airy Shaffer
burnt crystals and myself and we take
little jabs at each other and it's just
you know we just have fun crystals yeah
because it's the three of us and Joe but
you know we we have fun doing these
videos will put Instagram posts up and
would just say like I finished a class
so the other day Shaffir and Bert went
to a class together and as they left
they had the yoga instructor talk and
they were like they're like making fun
of me and Joe I forget with it but one
of the things I said they're like oh
you're seeing toe tom and then the guys
like all that little short guy because
that's one of like our ease jokes is
that I'm short and then he's like in the
blue Porsche and then and they're like
yeah he's like yeah and then like I saw
Bert and and are they so ridiculous like
such ridiculous car yeah and like he's
so cheesy you know driving his blue car
and I and I saw that and I was like
first of all it's not ridiculous and I
go if you want to see ridiculous
and you want to see cheesy we could step
this thing up to a whole other level you
know and I think like there's huge many
layers to the car thing for me and
particularly this car in particular that
I decided to rent and take to this yeah
first of all I'm a car nut like I'm a
fanatic I love cars if so many magazines
part you look at the pictures talk about
them hasn't changed since I was a kid
like yeah I used to play with little toy
cars you know read every car magazine
and I still buy them all the time I've
always I've gone to car shows I love it
I just love cars when you love cars
there they usually fall into different
categories for you you're like you know
that shit sucks I wish I could get those
like these are the cars I love and then
there's a category of car that you're
like I get that someone's into that but
it does nothing for me it's an absurd
thing it just it doesn't there's no it's
like if you want to relate it to like
human beings like someone saying isn't
that person attractive and you're like
doesn't do anything for me right just I
understand that you might think that
person's attractive right like you don't
want to fuck that guy right for free
room and board right but there's a
homeless guy out there that wants that
once the fuck desperately and pissing
and the beat on them just try it so
something for everybody there's
something for everyone for me
Lamborghinis oh my god fall into that
category
they just do nothing for me I see them
as comical ridiculous cars I see a
Lamborghini the same way I see somebody
with a pet tiger or like a mink coat or
like if somebody said like hey you like
shoes and I'd be like yeah I like shoes
they're like I got a shoes made of
diamonds yes you want to wear a
preposterous no I don't want to wear
that's that's a ridiculous it doesn't
there's nothing because it's so
outrageous out really borghini because
we've been joking about that's the thing
the senior joke it's longer than that
this is a joke where even though maybe
that 15 but like yeah you're right 10 to
12 years old like it's always been
just like a punch line to us Lambert
yeah who in their right mind like like a
you're saying because it's so it's so
flashy and garish yes it's like the
Sultan of Brunei has a Lamberg exactly
only people who really want attending a
lot of attention or just have so much
money to do to it they don't know and
the Lamborghini the the efficiency
there's no efficiency number one there's
no cup holders in a Lamborghini you
can't even you like your cup and put it
in there you can't recline the seats
because it's all and everything is made
of suede and leather so you can't even
spill or put a crumb in it yeah it's
such an absurd and the ones with the the
the doors that go up yeah like the wings
so what you're going to take your
Lamborghini to the grocery store were
you gonna park it one of my favorite
it's as crazy we've told this before but
it's been years favorite things we ever
did like as an ongoing joke of the
Lamborghini Lamborghini yes so
ridiculous ridiculous is a member of
years ago we were living in the rampart
division uh-huh yeah did not have a lot
of money money I mean like you know
we're trying to make rent yeah and I
called my dad and I go hey we're gonna
I'm gonna lease a Lamborghini and he
goes why and I go I'm gonna Lisa a
Lamborghini I said you know it's in LA
it's very important that you are
perceived a certain way and so I'm gonna
you know if that figured out like we
were to save some money cuz you go dad
you know when you pull up to like the
club yeah a comedy story Laugh Factory
you got to look like you're a big deal
yeah okay the polls I didn't like a
honda know you have to have a
Lamborghini people need to think that
you're really successful yeah and he was
like okay because I understand that I
said so you know like we're really gonna
have to put some money together but I'm
gonna lease this thing and it's you know
it's gonna be like nobody used you used
to tell him the math yeah I broke it
down I said we're putting like 30,000
and we could get together I'm borrowing
money from people all our savings and I
can only drive it 100
100 miles a month something like that
like something so stupid I support you
it was so sweet he was so sweet and
supportive yeah
he wasn't like that's the stupidest
fucking thing yeah he was he was like
okay like I get it I get it like you
yeah you got to look like you belong I
was like yeah he's like you're in show
business you got I look like you're
successful yeah so that one like that
did not get the reaction but I you know
when I told him I was like no I haven't
told him one time I was like I'm gonna
grow my hair out I'm gonna start combing
it back and I'm gonna grease it back and
I'm getting an earring and he was like
yeah you gotta stand out look different
like totally so wonderful because in LA
by the way the only time I've ever seen
a Lamborghini is parked in front of like
the Beverly Hills Hotel like some some
weirdo foreigner rented one that
philosophy that we're talking about of
like the standing out there are so many
people in this city who believe that
yeah they do go like I'm gonna grow the
hair out where the weird thing the
leather sleeveless yes because I want to
look like I'm different and everyone's
like no you're doing your are no because
it is a certain type of personality that
wants that Lamborghini level attention
yeah like I'm the guy that parks in
front of the hotel so that everybody
sees the car crazy it's not horrible
right I didn't like it let me tell you
the full the full details of this so I
fuckin go down there I go to this place
to rent it I look online again we always
talk about this by the way the first
place that I emailed and called never
even got back to me about rent it was
like one of the top-rated exotic rental
places I'm always I'm always just blown
away by the place that doesn't reply to
the person who's like here's my email my
phone number here's everything I want to
rent a Lamborghini tomorrow how can I
give you money and then you don't want
money and they're like advertising that
that's what they do it's crazy so this
place actually
replies you know they tell me here's our
cars we have it's called 777 exotics doc
and they're very you know very nice so I
go down there and then the plan is what
I'm going to do is go to hot yoga and I
have these water bottles that somebody
gave to us so the plan is I'll rent this
I'll get the Lamborghini I'll Park it
and then when I give them their water
bottles they'll see it you'll lure them
out to the car with the water wells
because that was the thing I was going
to ask you is well how are you gonna get
the guys out to the parking lot after
the class and everyone can send me
stupid exactly exam the truth is like I
really just wanted the truth is that I
would have just done this just for Bert
like that was that he was the mark you
know yeah like Joe and Ari are like
collateral damage like it sure it's a
Bert prank so I get down there and I'm
like which one should I get and they're
like how about this orange Lamborghini
who dicot and I go it's perfect
that's crazy this is perfect it's so
ridiculous I I leave the engine does
this kind of funky thing when I'm a few
miles away to you you're in the orange
lane the orange one I could not feel
like a bigger dick by the way everyone's
looking at me so horribly you know like
I actually lay low like I'm not like
check me out no so everyone's staring
people at stoplights you know feelin
like I saw I pulled out a driveway and I
saw a lady go like her her mouth dropped
and she was like but it looked horrified
yeah
and I roll down the window I go don't
get one it's stupid and she was like oh
like she caught herself yeah you're like
that would be the person where when I'm
with LJ yeah I go sweetie
that's a douchebag yeah yeah can you say
douchebag oh my god yeah so anyways the
engine did this crazy thing on its own
and it's like a spaceship in there I
mean everything's you have to tell you
like here's how you park here's here's
how you you know turn this here's how
the turn signal where it is none of its
intuitive can I ask you so did you put
your insurance policy honored you have
to take out an additional thing because
no such an expensive car
I used my own
risk but like I could've bought there as
I didn't I used my own but yeah yeah it
was a calculated risk I was like I'm not
gonna take this a lot of places I think
I think of it at home and then yeah hot
yoga back it's still a risk but I mean
you know it's a gamble but so anyways
the engine does some crazy thing that
I'm like what is it doing right now I
was like on its own revving so I just I
was like a couple miles away and I
called them and they're like well let us
check it out how about just stay where
you are and I'll bring you the
convertible the white convertible and I
go okay great I mean and for a second I
was disappointed was like oh no I don't
have the the orange absurd car but what
I realized as they pulled up and I
gotten the white one was that the white
one was more believable as how the way
that I would get because the orange was
too crazy it's too much of a haha no
no's joke they were good cuz when you
told me that you got the white one I go
oh that's even better yeah now Burt's
really gonna think that's what I put
together after I was because I was
driving I was like this is actually
believable yeah that you and and it was
a beautiful lever heating yeah yeah no
it's white and nothing owning like red
suede yeah interior I mean it was black
accents yeah I mean it's nuts these
thing drives unlike anything I've ever
been in and after telling you I'm
jumping ahead when I returned it the guy
goes do you want to go for a quick ride
in the Aventador which is the step-up
Lamborghini with like the doors that
slide up but also has a much crazier
engine and I remember thinking like how
much crazier could this drive than the
one that I've had for a day
the who duck on the way bukhan what does
that mean hurricane you expect oh oh
it's it's Italian or shitbag
so I get in the Aventador and I'm like
at first it starts and I'm like well I
already feels different like well car
was just so you know the button to to
start a Lamborghini is actually like a
launch pad button it's like you know
when you see in the movies you lift the
lever yeah it's like a switch for the
missile I mean it's an experience here's
the thing that whole the whole thing is
a fun experience I totally recommend
renting these cars yeah
hundred percent so anyways he took me a
couple blocks in the Aventador and I was
like this is ten times crazier than the
one I rent and he was like I know this
one's really fucking nuts and costs a
few hundred thousand dollars more geez
so anyways dialing it back now so the so
that night the night that I get it I
rent it I take it home and I have a show
at The Comedy Store and I go what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take it to the
store tonight and just you know Park
like it's normal
no big deal yeah and then go do my spot
and then go home because a lot of famous
comedians truth that and most people
wouldn't know this but a lot of really
famous successful rich comedians do that
well though they'll roll up in a crazy
car and then all the door guys will be
like whose fucking car is that and then
it's the talk of the comedy store of
comics everybody has exactly who pulled
up in the Ferrari know what I was hoping
was that none of the guys are at the
store that night and this way like like
rumors would start leaking because that
would be like a perfect ploy into it but
what happened was already got added to
the show I was doing and I saw a tweet
garlic oh we just added our exist show
and I'm like ooh then I was debating
like it's gonna blow the wad of having
it at you hot yoga then it's just like a
comedy store parking lot then yes and I
said then Bert cogs are you going store
tonight and I go yeah he goes I'll see
you there and then I go I'm not bringing
it because I want to save it for hot
yoga yeah that's better it's better in
the daytime and absolutely and also just
the four of us are not like the scene of
the story you don't explain it to all
the comics so I go to the store and I
wasn't gonna say anything to anybody but
as I'm leaving the store Joe was also
there he walks up to me and he's just
whatever just bullshit and
and I'm too excited I just get again you
know I mean when you're like excited
it's like we're excited about a joke
yeah I got this joke so I go out I tell
you I'm doing and he goes he was what I
said you know these guys made this video
and they were like all that porcius so
ridiculous
of course he's like how's that
ridiculous a love portion I know I know
I go well so what I'm gonna do is I tell
him I rent a Lamborghini he starts
laughing I'm just gonna play it not and
he goes oh yeah I go you got to help me
say he goes 100% I'll tell him you're
doing great what's the why not yeah
what's the big deal enjoy life like what
you can do is save all your money it's
like it is perfectly lined up then the
next move is I get you know the next day
I'm just way cuz you came home and then
you told me that Joe is in there now I
am here to ear because I think it's more
powerful if Joe does know yeah now he
and you can kind of gang up on Bert and
re and convince them that no this is a
really good idea this is what successful
men do what's wrong with you you're the
ass exactly by the way how much are
Lamborghinis just so that alright so for
people that don't know the one that I
was driving some people online I have to
say guess it was a two thousand five or
six it is a 2017
Brent like its brand new had thirty
eight hundred miles on it so it's out of
the straight from the factory man that
one was three hundred and fifty thousand
that Aventador that he took me for a
ride and after it was five hundred
thousand crazy yes a lot half a mil this
is 350 that's craziness it's real nuts
it's fuckin nuts
it's silly unless you're a billionaire
it's just silly it is it's it's a
sicilius which is the most fun to
pretend like to me the amusement in this
like the the joy in this would be to
pretend like what's the big deal
like and but I mean like to really sell
it and that's what I kept imagining is
that birds gonna freak out
I'm just gonna go like what I make a lot
of money or just just be like but what
was what am I gonna say for my kids
college tuition that scholarships not a
big deal but also like that's not that
much yeah big deal so I don't so of
course I am just I'm John like I'm so
antsy to go to class I want to make sure
that I'm early because I didn't want to
blow the like the show of it before
class for some reason that we're sure
not gonna be as fun right so I shut up
like half an hour early and funny enough
as I'm pulling in the hot yoga my phone
rings I'm like pulling in the parking
lot and it's Joe and I answer he goes
you got a white one behind you
Lamborghini and I go yeah he's like
that's fucking crazy
so we park like away from where I
normally parks it wasn't like you know
normally I park in one section of the
parking lot yeah I parked away from it
and I go so after class I go I'll tell
you and RI got your water bottles from
this guy that sent him to us over here
he's like all right cool so we go to
class wait and that by the way is my
favorite part of the story of like
luring them to the car and being lights
or water bottles right here in the trunk
which is in the front of this car yeah
then you're like oh what's the big deal
it's my Lamborghini and I'm getting
water bomb it was such a great moment
you know so like I really wanted to sell
this hard so the way to sell it I
thought was to be very nonchalant oh
yeah you have to be like this is what I
did what's the deal
we finished class we're walking back and
we're just talking about like at the
time we had finished you know I think
Ari and I had finished number 14 Joe and
Bert had just finished number 13 so
we're talking this and that and it's
like oh what are you doing tomorrow what
he doing the next day blah blah blah and
we start walking Ari and Joe are ari and
Burke had rode together so they're
walking this way and I go I got your
water bottle he's like oh yeah sorry
really wanted he goes yeah I want that
water bottle so go come here we start
walking and you know you're starting to
see there's less cars that
could be mine so it's like we're walking
and I hear Burton got a Lamborghini over
he says that I reach in my pocket and I
press unlock and he goes and you know
some people that's like like my told my
cousin Brian about it he's like you got
a record and I was like if I just pull
out my phone immediately and announce
too obvious so it was I think it was
important to try to like dial it back a
little bit yeah
so I go home I go you want that water
bottle right like I didn't even address
I opened there he like is he keep
hearing burgling so I open the front
hood which you can put a fucking laptop
in in a Lamborghini and I pull you on
your water bottle I give it to Joe Joe
is of course he's like fuck yeah dude
your balls yeah he's like wait way to go
Tommy
he's like sick sick and Ari is like oh
like not really saying much she's doing
his re think yeah he's doing his ari
thing Bert immediately goes what you
rented this I go no and he goes and he's
looking at me like he's ignoring Joe and
re talking he's like like really eyeball
me cuz he he's like did you are you
serious
and I go yeah I go is that crazy he's
like you bought a Lamborghini yeah
that's a great year yeah and then
special no teeth no Angela know what
Netflix
don't worry that you rented this and I
go no and the thing is since it's a new
car it has that the VIN number VIN
sticker yeah I don't like the
registration I go check my registration
and it's still on there and right then
our egos check his registration and as
he says that and I go oh I think they're
actually gonna go try to look at the
registration Joe like says something
else and it distracts them so they go
back to the
conversation then we start like the
things they're like what the fuck I go I
got a great deal I go the owner drove it
for like three weeks so I got like 40
grand off and I pay like 3,000 I mean I
thought that was a good deal it's a good
deal yeah and I'm just like totally like
not you know giving in I'm like yeah
that's awesome and you should see how
this works so I started like when we
turn on and turn the car on and Bert's
like I just fucking who are you it was
um me see if I can he made this video
save this place fun Instagram how funny
um and then the one thing I'd like to
say about me and my friends is that Fame
hasn't changed in any of us you hang out
with Joe he's Bohanon is Jiu Jitsu
it's fucking marijuana Ari Shaffir
backpacking through Asia by himself he
could go backpack right now if you
wanted to buy Lambos with the fucking
brains blown out it's like we're friends
with mace and Puff Daddy
holy fucking shit
so funny such idiots but I could see you
know I could see Bert's still like we
would have a moment like that like for
your video and then people can't you
know you start to regroup like and he
would just look over I see him being
like what he's in his mind he's math I
could see the back he's like how many
tickets is Tommy so he was the POC how
much how much per their broadcast be me
even when we said like we said bye to
each other yeah we all got in our I got
my car and I started to back up I turn
and he's just looking he was like he
says he was like could you imagine him
going home to Leanne and be like I could
push it's gotta be so much oh my god
yeah oh my god and I started to think
about - how much fun it would be if like
the whole fun was the idea of him
spiraling to the point of buying
something like the dream would would be
that he was like like something and then
have him show up like pulling the store
like well cuz also last night when you
when you got home I was like well
wouldn't it be great we're thinking of
ways to fuck with Bert further if you
and Joe could kind of team up and be
like you know they had to get into Italy
yes you can get into one for like I
texted him I last night I texted him I
go oh my life is so fun like it's not
that unreasonable Bert you're making a
lot of money this year yeah I texted him
last night I go want me to put you in
touch with my guy you can get you into
one for under two hundred thousand
artifacts you're our agent yeah sure was
well that was fun well so now our agent
called me up about you know
and some dates and I go his name is
Andrew I go Andrew
have you seen my husband social media he
goes no I my husband got fucking
Lamborghini and I am furious I'm furious
you need to call him right now and
convince him to return it because I am
beside myself with anger and he goes ok
I'm on it and then he calls you and then
to which he told him the truth I told
him after he goes hey Tom hey it's me
I'm from your local Lamborghini
dealership make sure everything's
working alright and I go oh yeah I'm
real happy with him man and you know
then he kind of dropped character he
goes so wow you got a Lamborghini and I
go yeah he's like yeah Christina said
she wasn't too thrilled about it and I
go yeah he goes he was everything I want
to say congratulations and I go Thanks I
could tell that he was like he's like
you great yeah until I tell him he
started to laugh really hard and I go
did you think I was totally unstable for
a second he was absolutely yeah because
I really was like wow this guy I thought
I knew him a little bit yeah Adam Adam
from the store today texted me I shut up
he did yeah I texted me um he goes he
was I was gonna text you yesterday see
if you had lost your fucking bill burr
texted me last night and I think really
made the rounds he wrote like please
take you know pictures he goes congrats
on your new ride and and it felt like
kind of sincere you know so I thought I
go I didn't get one I just rented one to
mess with Bert ha ha ha and he wrote I
love it all capital letters hilarious so
it was so then anyways and I had made
this video when I was when I dropped it
off and then I posted it a few hours ago
just after I had talked to Bert this
morning I talked to Bert this morning
and we had a conversation that went you
know left and right it wasn't like about
it and then I was like yeah I know
so the main thing is like I definitely
don't want things with us to ever change
because like I have a Lamborghini
alright
like we'd still be friends Berger yeah
he was like no it's fucking it's it's
look amazing
he was real sincere about it he's sweet
and as soon as I hung up I wrote yo Bert
have you seen this and I have posted
this on guys
jig is up I didn't buy a Lamborghini
to get the keys back
[Music]
I did I went to 777 exotics calm calm
this is not a paid sponsorship I paid I
rented it you can too
I highly recommend doing that as opposed
to I basically just said you know at the
end of this I go I got you bird like
that yeah it was really just to see Burt
and then he called me you fucking dick
you to fucking yes you had the whole
time I was so blown away like there's no
way he's that fucking stupid suspend 300
South fools
40 grand on it I'm City shit by the way
you didn't have I was being real in the
moment and I know Joe was in on it he
had to be in on it because I've seen his
work on this radio is not that good the
whole time I was like look man you know
Ari was like I was in the car the whole
time I thought I left
dude there's no way he'd be I got Tom's
not that stupid he's not that always
like dude this one
he's from this reporting that's what
they I was like to dump reporters I got
a difficult different rows I can't have
going through and looking at motorcycles
on my last night
because I was having a feeling of being
left out exactly a motorcycles all mine
that can't afford to pay 10 grand I can
only one spend five grand on a hot grill
okay by a bullshit fixer-upper
motorcycle for fucking ten grand Leon's
gonna kill me
I just started GoFundMe
you enjoy a fucking hour holds barred
hilarious eat all you know I knew the
bird I'm pausing oh I wanted to go dogs
need to eat ok ok let's pause there
after Bert's voicemails somebody know
where Reese up and I want us all right
we're back that was a quick break I
think the best my favorite part of this
whole thing first of all that was some
of the best money I ever spent was
renting that car and I would say again
for car enthusiasts it was really fun to
rent a car that you're not committing to
buying yeah even ones that aren't that
expensive renting a fun car to drive is
a fun thing to do
I totally get that my favorite thing
though is that I you know I talked to
bird after this and he was like he was I
knew it I just knew that you weren't
that stupid you would do that but that
Arie was like he's definitely dumb
enough to do that oh yeah right Arie was
like Harry Ari called me white trash huh
and then I was from Florida and that
Florida people are stupid and that we
would definitely buy that that is so
damn rude I know how dare you arrey
arrey is that's how he is you know so
anyways that was a lamp lambo Frank I
think that's you know No No maybe Lambo
prank a hundred percent worth it so fun
to see Bert's face so fun to get him to
to spiral he was searching for
motorcycles last night online I knew he
would react that way I call it yeah I go
there's no way he is right now in his
mind counting how much you're making and
then he's gonna find a way to match what
you're doing to Peyton someone you know
what I bet LeAnn last night was just
like oh my gosh
go fund me and with them she is proud so
I know you guys are some machines within
remixes they keep coming in it's my
favorite thing right it is so fantastic
[Music]
[Applause]
this is machines within by Michael
Hodgdon he turned out
[Music]
yeah
you like it yeah this is how I hear that
I heard it in my head
it's how I heared it see right here did
I heard it
[Music]
it's great by the way this Halloween
season - perfect
we're gonna Murat rice it's a good song
[Music]
I like it Michael good job working on
the flow working on the flows all the
haters haters here is F all the haters
rage against the machines within oh my
god why didn't we think of that by Pete
from one-and-a-quarter okay
that's who made this one here Pete yeah
like that I like that terminator yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
good it's really good yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
TSST TSST TSST
so 16 she
[Music]
[Applause]
it's pretty good it's really good
by the way I think I already said this
but I don't know if I said it only to
you off camera and not on the show but
the other really crazy thing that
surprised me going back to the Lambo
thing was how many people were like the
internet always kicks you in the balls
I got like hundreds and hundreds of
people being like so happy for you
people were like oh you're rich fuck you
which was like all right man
like that was their take on it I got it
like I used to like you so critics such
a crazy reaction yeah but the majority
of people were like so happy for you man
yeah graduation I will say that our our
fans are genuinely nice very nice sweet
and supportive of stuff and that's it is
so refreshing on the internet which is a
wasteland of hatred yeah that's what I'm
saying I know so it's nice that just
that was just a real quick
I know it doesn't make a nice comment on
Twitter or anywhere it blows me away
when people are kind you're like what
you know I'm in this douche-mobile
and it's $300,000 and like people are
just gonna be like and there was a few
but if you read through the comments on
my Instagram and it's mostly people
going
you earned it congratulations with it
man machines within yeah I did see a
bunch of machines with him yeah but
anyways I thought that was actually very
surprising yes machines women also came
in with video and music submissions get
the fuck outta you have a few of these
OMG
machines we then machines within yeah
I'm talking about machines with ban
terminator gun somebody gonna terminate
a gun Luke Luke you killed it with the
redneck version of machines within
incredible that harmonica work is
amazing guys a really talented harmonica
player right there that was really
actually and I don't I'm not a huge fan
of the harmonica yep and I really
enjoyed that that's great yeah that
guy's talented yeah there's more Tommy
Christina this is a ukulele version and
machines have been pulled away from the
UK podcast
[Music]
crabbers crabbers yeah dude thank you
that was awesome fantastic amazing
audience we have you know international
international and that was another one
came in shut up Nate from Indy all right
[Music]
the second song yeah on the album
[Applause]
machines
[Music]
she crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
what is real
[Applause]
[Music]
hey hey
[Applause]
what's amazing wow that's a Nate from
Indy incredible so many I mean I feel
like I'm serious that there's so many
incredibly musically inclined people
listen to this show I'm who knew such
talented people I thought was all just
Daryl X like us that listen I know but
there's really talented people I'm a
little disappointed that we didn't get a
song you know but you can only get some
we didn't get it she's retarded so let
me see do I see I don't I don't see one
no I was thinking that the she's
retarded that could be a fun prank for
spouses you could say that about your
wife or husband in public when they act
up yeah we think this email oh that's
interesting right design these twins
conjoined twins if they get a job do
they get one salary or two damn it
machines within F the haters Nathan that
is an excellent question I hope that
machines within F the haters replaces
hate Hitler yeah me too
believe me especially as your I hope
you're touring starts to only pick up
now and you hear as many times as I did
this year walking to the stage as you
get onstage and as the applause dies you
know and they settle in for you talk and
you're like hello and then they go well
I was at Twitter yesterday doing the
Twitter Q&A yeah sanim oh my god it was
so super fun is that it's not official
HQ right that's up north but right it's
like Twitter la there's offices in
Denver San Francisco all these million
places and you know a lot of its mommies
asking questions and most of them were
like hey Hitler just wondering blah blah
blah blah and the girls are like why is
everybody saying hey Hitler it's a it's
a joke I dropped my joke book and at
yoga I didn't know it and our egos she
dropped this goose and I go now he goes
it's not here no book oh my golly it's
my notebook and he opened it
it says hey Hitler and I go no that is
mine it was like okay like this is
Hitler and it's yours I'm like yes mine
to tell that story to somebody it was on
my set list yeah
a hot dump question hey mommies you know
they say if you drink milk with spicy
foods it takes away something spicy I'm
wondering if you were to pour milk on
how you say asshole would it ease the
pain of hot dumps do you think love you
Gabe what a real thought-provoking other
really good question gosh I mean I don't
see why it wouldn't if it works on your
mouth with spices yeah you know what
else cools your hiney is a total wash
let 350 eat just splashing some water on
your hiney yes yes why I'd argue that
any liquid really help is holy yeah it
keeps your asshole yeah good question
I'm really interested if there's any
employers who have hired or been around
a conjoined twin to see if they get two
salaries because they have separate
rights they have their own individual
rights why there's two separate people
yeah they have different mind so how
could you be like well we're just gonna
pay you this one thing
it can't be because they are two
separate entities there are two separate
people with different social security
numbers innate in question right yeah
they have I'm sure they have you know
lice and not dry I don't think and can
they drive yeah they can who's the
driver I don't know how do you wipe if
you have no arms that came in damn it
I was taking such a good dump today
began thinking about people who are
unable to have such a time on the toilet
lack my pondering of poop ravage of this
question how do people without arms wipe
their ass I'm really at a loss here I
what I'm really at a loss at is not how
they wipe at all how do you wipe outside
of the home because I'm sure there's a
system you would set up at home you know
there would be with a rag on it
something I don't know off the top of my
butt yeah I can imagine
that there's something you would set up
right like a friend a bidet and
and some somehow advice how you push the
button for the bidet it's a great
question I mean these are you know I'm
saying that but there's something iffy
there no armed people out there gonna
find us and let us know there's some
system but it's more interesting to me
as like what about an emergency dump out
on the town that's really curious I mean
I'm guessing own if you're armless you
might have a helper with you know at all
times no and then how do you how do you
get around you gotta walk everywhere oh
no I guess you can't dig in uber now how
most people don't have helpers I'd I'd
have a helper if I were or no you won't
sure can't reach anything yeah but how
are you gonna how you gonna get your
iPhone out and hit goober come get you
Jesus you've no arms why is that a
ridiculous question
they don't have helper is there like a
prosthetic and they you know if they
don't they still can you can do what you
can walk around and do what you need to
do without an arm nope two arm two arms
miss they don't have a helper this
person did not mention prosthetics I am
literally imagining somebody with no
arms right now they still don't be like
I love arms I need a full-time caregiver
it's not how that works they would still
they make do without their arms
it's what's interesting is how they do
it it's not a helper okay not a helper
well I don't know much about the armless
kin I'm just saying it's a fascinating
question it is a fascinating question if
you're black and you want to rent free
lifestyle fuck me come over here and
fuck me right now whatever you want piss
on me slap me hit me in my own eyes try
it out my bills and try it out much like
a piss let me try it out fuck man I'm
looking for hardcore guys and me we know
you are and I want to deliver it I'm a
hot pot my trash come dump let's fuck
his teeth don't look good either
nothing's going on good black guys who
love to fuck and fuck good if you're a
hot black guy who do you think's
creepier okay would you rather would you
rather you're a hot black guy yeah would
you rather bang ugly ron jeremy
yeah and ron jeremy ain't so good this
is his retarded brother yeah
dawn Jeremy so would you rather bang
this guy down Jeremy yeah or the 2016
benadryl guy oh my god he's they're both
super horny okay
it's a filler up stealer shut up are you
doing the 16 benadryl guy or there first
of all as always I applaud you and your
impromptu filler ups and would you a
you're really gifted at this yeah this
is what I would take for the network's
to pitch if I were you if you were pitch
an idea you know I am looking to pitch
show a dog dick afternoon yeah yeah
right come come with the tools with the
man love in the middle right good liking
farting on dogs heads is another TV show
so far I mean I could see NBC ABC Fox
CBS we're also gonna take this thing
broadcast network shows yeah okay so who
are you gonna bang is that the 16
benadryl here's why it's interesting to
me here's the good news they're both
enthusiastic lovers
they're both definitely not not horny
you're right charge just to remind
people who you're talking about
horny for two or three hours like you've
never been in your life you have access
to marijuana - mm-hmm good weed listen
to me okay true we - Lunken gets you
really hornier the normal but it's been
on drill take about 10 12 billion girl
before you want to have your sexual fun
with your partner or whatever you do or
masturbate alright have a heart attack
go to the hospital this hundred yard
stare that's permanently in his eyes
there's definitely plans and plots on
the wall behind him of people to take
out him and his benadryl in his week
with this closet though he does have a
nice closet behind it he's following
fucking cash for bubble lewd light a
laughing gas or whatever it so it's him
do I want to fuck him or ladies the
laying down no homeless lorem you're a
thug I'm gonna come move in a friend
come with you man
free-range Achilles Mikey fuck me piss
somebody beat me at home ya know see me
wanna come over today and try it out try
it out man
yeah I mean they're too great you know
we got to do a style that's different
styles you know what I wish we could do
is like a dating game where we can match
the perfect homeless person with either
of these gentlemen yeah yeah no that's
good and they answer questions but you
know it's just silly fun so what do you
I mean we could add a third how about
the fuck me in my ass now let's keep it
to the homeless guy gets raped by a
ghost no I think it's good to keep it to
the two guys that can string sentences
together but who are you going for it's
a good it's really good because it
they're both alarming individuals and
terrifying in different ways see I think
a lot of people terrifying in different
ways is an excellent frame yeah a lot of
people would in this situation be like
I'm staying away from the fucking me for
free rent black guy why is that well
it's just it seems so direct and
aggressive sure and the aggression can
be off-putting to some people you go you
go oh the benadryl guy he's pretty chill
he's just sitting on the couch he's just
like smoke some weed but that guy has
some really really scary things going on
that you didn't necessarily see in that
video luckily for us we have more than
one video of him do you think he's
making a suit out of lady skin and he's
got a girl in a well I think the
benadryl guy is scarier actually I think
there's a lot below the surface that's
what I'm saying the Benedick he's got a
girl that he's starving to make a lady
drunk I would never so much my family's
tried to get me to watch regular porn
they call it fuck you and your phone
and your the way you make out and your
stupid boring fucking bullshit mm-hmm
okay this guy in a cabin with a that
only he has the key to is this is the
end of your life for sure but wait have
a free ride guys like beat the piss out
of me but that's what he's saying - he's
like I don't like regular know I like
wild stuff what's wrong with you the
other guy likes wild stuff too you want
to be adventurous you like that the
other guy's direct in that he wants
basically to be submissive he wants you
to be very dominant and aggressive this
guy like that do you like how you like
taking the lead I don't know extra thing
you're always in when you know right I'm
thinking the only thing that's gonna I'm
gonna problem with the other guys I'm
not black that's gonna piss him off well
okay let's let's lift that Lamborghini
Burgamy
let's lift that requirement for this for
the sake of this fill er up sealer shut
yeah now this guy's a serial killer
you like serial kill no no I like
watching shows about them I don't like
them you like them creepy no the two of
you could talk about killing millions
all of your own by your woman you're all
a bunch of fucking pieces of shit
anymore
Here I am on the planet with your
motherfucker hmm have a good day
motherfucker oh that's how my mom used
to end her letters those pupils huh the
pupils are wild it is in the eyes with
this guy he's severely mentally ill is
that or just whacked out on the drugs
the drugs aren't helping the mental
decline yeah put it that way I think I'd
have to fuck the guy that once we get
pissed on for rent and good news free
rent
you don't bring that part I got a
mortgage Jesus right yeah you're saving
cash with that guy the mustache guy
you're having a good time everyone's
it's a win-win you think he'd pick up my
lambo payments I don't know if he's
capable of that no but I mean he is
giving you something too which is nice
free rent you can you can bring a friend
hardcore guys magic at least in a cage
fuck me
at Elysee and a key yeah Wow now and you
can also bring a buddy along so which
buddy are you bringing along oh that's
interesting I've been I would either
bring along Bert or sickle-cell or re
you know any any of those dudes would be
down I mean Ari's kind of homeless all
the time yeah he kind of has like
homeless guy vibes yeah he does he looks
homeless sorry yeah for sure yeah but
you look dirty and you look like you you
know you live on the streets he's like
you will come in here piss on me fuck me
for rent okay now see I oh man if I were
a guy I guess in order to fill er up and
sealer shut I would have to be a guy in
this scenario mm-hmm
I'm gonna have to go with you on this
one because I am afraid that the
Benadryl guy yeah I might kill you cut
you up yeah so you would you would piss
on and beat the other guy sure and put a
strap on it it's free rent and a buddy
gets to come along he once he he wants
to be nailed so sure you'd do the
strap-on yeah no problem no prob yeah no
I'll practice before I go in on whoever
is here in front of me I don't know you
won't let me practice on you no babe
we're talking Lambo payments he said I
don't think he could take over those
payments if it's 320 or 350
that's ridiculous you put 10,000 down
and then your monthlies only like 20
grand
let's do it's preposterous okay if you
can't if you're not a multi-millionaire
you're the car loan calculator yeah
okay she's retarded
yeah $350,000 yeah but let's say how
many months cuz they tell you it's
really stupid to do longer than like 36
months well let's do the financial
advisors tell you like you know pay it
off within two to three years so let's
say three years okay three year
Lamborghini otherwise you're paying way
too much in interest so
sure let's do 36 we're all about the
value with this you know 3% interest
sure all right let's see all right so
that's a pretty good deal I mean that's
a low interest rate yeah
36 months they're loaning you $350,000
so your monthly payments are only ten
thousand one hundred seventy eight
dollars a month for your car for your
car makes sense yeah and then you're
talking great mileage on the gas yeah
hey I drove it 60 miles and I took down
a little over a quarter of a tank so
yeah I mean you're filling up often
you're filling it up like every day yeah
like pretty much every day every other
day you're filling up your tank like $60
a pop I don't know fill up yeah 60s all
right that's good
you can only take a one person throw
that on the 10 grand your monthly loan
what about insurance it's gonna be not a
joke to insure first you're insuring a
house month for a car yeah that is
bananas yeah that is a huge mortgage
payment it's pretty one goodness we can
do that that's crazy yeah man okay let's
see this but I will say that Lamborghini
that that is just for the pleasure of it
there is no utility in a Lamborghini it
is all just for fun it is all pleasure
and joy which you know I don't I don't
know anything about what are you looking
to I'm trying to figure out the what the
insurance would be in California well
there's so many uninsured motorists
because that's what you're paying for
isn't the people that don't have
insurance could you imagine could you
imagine getting hit in that car and then
you got to replace the fucking the door
that goes where the guy told me I go cuz
I was telling him I was like it's so
crazy to get into this business you have
of buying exotic cars and then renting
them because you're overhead like to get
into the business
yeah he's like five million dollars
right yeah he has like rolls-royce
Bentley's Ferraris Maseratis you know
all these exotic cars and he's like yeah
it's crazy and I was like it's just so
much fun he goes oh yeah when the
transmission blew on one of these Lambos
it was a $45,000 to fix the transmission
it's like the service on these things is
no joke you know it does make me think
how many people in LA are doing that
exact thing that they are just renting
these fancy cars now that I know it's a
lot it's a lot yeah and now that I'm
like oh what's that guy doing with a
Ferrari like these people are probably
renting there's a lot of renter's yeah
yeah he told me how like the business
does well yeah especially in Beverly
Hills and you know people want to look
like know where you know where it's more
obvious when you if you like want to pay
attention to to where how it's going if
you see a Lamborghini or a Ferrari on a
residential street
that's probably owned when you see them
parked or up and down Rodeo
oh yeah that's and that whole thing
that's a renter that's somebody who got
it for a trip which is I understand
though I came to LA I'm gonna drive up
rich people Boulevard yeah and I'm gonna
get this crazy let's go to Rodeo let's
rent a crazy car yeah let's go shopping
at the you know whatever poyo store
Ralph Lauren yeah well this is uh what
the fuck people buy this is super
exciting we've been working on this for
a minute and it's finally here we've
talked about it for a while we have a
holiday collection of your mom's house
related products coming out they're out
now a couple of them are on sale a
couple our presale so this first one was
the big one this is our first ever
Christmas sweater and it is amazing it
is one of the best things I have ever
seen it's a it's a Christmas a legit
Christmas sweater and it says Santa
Claus wears jeans and it has Santa and
he's wearing his jeans
and here's what's really cool about this
100% of the profit that comes from the
santa claus wears jeans Christmas
sweater will go to the Children's
Hospital of Los Angeles we're going to
donate to their toy program wonder kids
that are in the hospital and will
document it so it's not just like yeah
just believe it we're gonna you know
make a video of like the shopping and
and dropping off some of the toys and
gift cards and stuff there's no better
cause no better cause so please check it
out go to Tom Segura calm and click on
my store or go to merch method calm
slash Tom Segura we also have a couple
other this it's a red Christmas sweater
the Santa Claus wears jeans it's red and
it's got the white stitching of like
snowflakes and it's got it colored jeans
it's great it's a real Christmas teddy
yeah you're gonna wear it you're
actually gonna wear it great too the Hat
the winter hat
with the little ball on top with
snowflakes and it says Santa Claus wears
jeans of course that's a very fun and
then this is something that like I've
held on to I wanted to do this for years
and I finally did it
we're doing Christmas sweatshirts as
well in different colors white green and
red and who are you to tell me what
Santa Claus looks like is my so now we
have Santa Claus is black yeah tag ymh
right you don't know my pronoun you know
don't assume it we have Santa Claus is
Asian no yes I love it he is oh that's
great Santa Claus is Asian Santa Claus
is black I love it and we also have for
ED - we have Santa Clauses Latino yes
dude in a green and he's wearing a
sombrero and hashtag white anyway so
Sasa like I said some of these are
presale and they'll ship in like about
three and a half weeks some of these are
on sale meaning they'll ship in less
time maybe two weeks so that's our get
them now what you're saying is get
now before the it gets really cold yeah
for the holidays really can't get your
Christmas stuff now it's great you know
Christmas present if your significant
other is a podcast fan or you just want
to have like a more unique holiday
sweater or sweatshirt the Hat is awesome
I have the Hat they should they shipped
it to us and I tell you the quality of
all of these items Remo quality is
impeccable well I have the Hat yeah in
our bedroom it's good yeah and again
that was the sweater all of them are
great Santa Claus wears jeans the
sweaters incredible all going to
children's charity that's awesome too
right now very cool so very proud of
that charity now to one of the more
exciting things that we have come across
and some time here on this show very
happy to bring to your attention nope
that did not go as planned Jean here it
is I screwed it up I'm you different so
that you know what happened yeah another
shoe dropping in the wake of the Harvey
Weinstein sexual harassment scandal
engulfing Hollywood new accusations
against action stars ago no daily mail
TV brings to light an audio tape which
Seagal reveals his outrageously profane
attitude toward female journalists
[Music]
a promotional tour he's there to talk
about his help not about who's you know
who his wife was with ten years ago I
should go into pornography journalism
they want to hear that so unfortunately
the the bleeps were unavoidable sure I
hate playing censored stuff on this
podcast but that's that's the only
version that exists right now this is
all related to a story that broke you
know like everyone's being taken down
right now for sexual harassment you know
all these things so there's a story that
came that a woman who auditioned for one
of when he was like you know making big
100 million dollar or whatever maybe not
now yeah now they're like thousand
dollar budgets but when he was doing
those about 20 years ago a woman claims
that she was got the call like oh so
called considering you for the lead you
need to go to his house and she had the
wherewithal to bring the casting
director with her and he answered in
like a silk robe and he just sat in the
chair and watched her audition and then
when she left she got the call that like
Oh Steven thought you did great
he needs you to come back to do a
private rehearsal oh yeah oh the private
rehearsal in the Renny still in his robe
for it well she turned it down okay and
so he gave her like a one-line part Wow
this story came out a couple weeks ago
and this stuff is in relation to those
story like wow him telling somebody else
about that you know
and who seems to justice to all you and
all this and that he's so mad at her for
this yeah cuz this you know this bad
press man there's no and Stevens used to
a very high standard of good press yeah
being a Russian recent citizen and and
and you know of sorts and he you know
he's a talented guy and I am the king of
in province for forgive my saying so
geez think of improv yeah yeah wow I
don't know and I I really hope he does
more ideas like this Heidi - I was just
looking at his photo there without the
jet black mustache on the jet black I
think he might look better if he shaved
that off just cut it all off right but
keep the the gun range yellow sunglasses
right he stopped wearing those he has
little ones now he went to the John
Lennon's yeah a tiny spectacles
those are good look much better and the
the hairpiece is darker and more full
than it was I like that too I mean I you
know Ryan Sickler our good friend had a
goatee for 15 years and he just shaved
it off about a year ago yeah he looks 10
years younger
I just saw him I did the crab feast your
go and I mean it's like a different man
yeah I think there is an age where you
should take off the goatee yeah yeah
he's just ageing him it's not good yeah
just be fat I mean at this point it
might look better just to have a fat
face like that no and the way that the
hair is cut it's actually making his
cheeks look puffier I know he needs to
either a growing expand the width of
that beard oh my god or just cut it off
or or lose weight you know I could do
that oh my god and he look it's a great
I get a weave yeah that's so dark it's
so so dark who's his plugs aren't aren't
good
he's wearing his ghee to meet Putin yeah
Vladimir Putin yeah he's wearing a
fucking ghee eating his carrier to the
Kremlin or wherever it is he's getting a
carrot sure such a weird yeah he looks
so weird such a weird look that he's got
going yeah yeah those tiny glasses that
he look at him back did he look how much
thinner he was here that's him yeah no
yeah that's him that's him in his heyday
are you sure that's not Yanni no that's
the Stevens ago you gotta be kidding
yeah it's back in the days he was
attractive well yeah he's fucking
superstar man yeah he looks terrible but
that one that one interview he did he
had those crazy crazy glasses on that
whereas here it is this one right yeah
it looks like a cartoon character
yeah look good look here this isn't how
long ago is that that's old oh because
he Lee he's handsome yeah yeah take this
take the facial hair off how you gonna
act like you didn't know he was handsome
I didn't really I did not know the gun
it's you see but that makes me look 10
times crazier you know it's not it's not
helping him to wear the ghee and the
glasses in public it's just this is not
that you just look crazy yeah no you
need to normalize the look a little I
agree I don't you feel like kini he just
needs to look more normal yeah it's just
not good you know you start you start to
do crazy or other things to distract
from your body going ahead what happens
is like he's just gained so much weight
that he's like you know grow this put
some sunglasses because you're trying to
distract
yeah from from things going to shit you
know yeah yeah I mean it's just so you
know we were talking about it today as
we were driving around the neighborhood
and we saw a man wearing like those
cavalry Chi pants from the 90s and then
he had a belt and then the shirt tucked
into the terrible 90s pants the Hammer
pants and it's because nobody loves
nobody loves him and I think the problem
with Steven Seagal is that he doesn't
have a woman in his life who tells him
he looks ridiculous or
loves him who loves him she look any
woman in his life is like here that
movie star yeah you're the action star
good you know what you you're handsome
without the jet black widow's peak in
the the jet black goatee you look
terrible with that yeah it's stupid I
don't let you out of the house with even
you you almost went out of the house of
the day to a pitch meeting wearing a
denim button-down shirt and the denim
that's right I mean I'm your my image
for life hello
yeah but not not to that meaning yeah I
didn't let Chad the house cuz why cuz
why did you love me yes that's right
Thank You Jean hailer I haven't I in
lost a question that came in I have an
in-law that is quite heavy handed with
the you know what I mean
Oh am I supposed to answer yes I know
what you mean every time I'm asked to
follow along with the dumb story at what
point am I supposed to stop replying
what's the etiquette for taking this
kind of blast yeah I mean thanks for the
giggles Roger you know I'm saying now I
said you know what I mean or you know
what I'm saying this person says you
know what I mean
fuck you know what I mean you know I
mean yeah yeah you know what I mean know
what I mean you know what I mean you
know and I do check it out you want
saying it's a fear you know saying you
know saying I'm like you know job damn
my life in that jail you know I'm saying
I don't know I'm like you know what I'm
saying I feel like I feel like you got a
ha ha ha you got to kind of leave that
you know I means a loan you can't really
start answering them Mitch
it's mixed yeah yeah you know I'm saying
neutral humming good motherfucker right
there yeah I'm saying
so you know I'm saying he's like well
here's the thing one time I was watching
mom discipline her kid yeah who kept
saying like um this little boy was
learning to speak right what four years
old so different and he kept going and
like um and like and like um and the mom
goes don't stop saying like um do you
don't say like um and at the time I
thought gosh it's kind of cruel it kind
of then it puts this thing in that kid's
head like self-consciousness
then again it is a verbal tic and until
somebody points it out to you you need
to become cognizant of it it's not bad
yeah maybe if he answered him with the
same amounts of is it you know you know
I'm saying or you know you know I mean
yeah maybe if it was like well you know
what I mean you know I mean you mean
like you know joke I think what would be
funny is what he's proposing is to go
like what you mean I know what you mean
I know what you mean I know what you
mean I know what you mean I know what
you mean she's retarded yeah yes I know
what you mean that's true he did do that
yeah you know there was a time in high
school when my BFF Shana and I we said
like a lot because we're valley girls
yeah there was a point where she and I
had to correct each other and we had to
we had to be like like hey we're saying
like way too much and you were calling
each other out we're calling each other
out because we we realized that it I'd
like it like I had gotten like too far
like like too far and how did it help
yeah Shauna brought up I remember she
goes I think we're saying like too much
bro and I was like what like like what
like what bro like yeah cuz she's like
she's like we were saying like too much
she said she goes Oh cuz I heard my
brother on the phone and I think he was
saying it you know that's always how it
is and then you go wait am i saying that
stuff too I say like too much now of
course we both we're in California
that's the land of like yeah like like
like like like like bro like like like
like
we-we've we're leaving for the camping
trips on the 20th
oh boy holds all go on me feign mommy
daddy nikki grammatically incorrect me
hey Danny we have a bunch of us going
and you and Grandpop are supposed to
come okay why what am I gonna paint shit
they give us old buckets with our names
on it what does that mean well you can't
go in my bucket and I can't go in yours
so we don't get germs spreading germs
spread but where do I put my AZ
I think you played with yourself why
would you say that to me papi put it in
the bucket and then at the end we do you
gotta shit though it's fighting like a
like a tree give me either tricky yeah
sweet old lady yeah he's being told that
she's gonna have to shit in a bucket if
she goes on this trip
man you can't ask some old lady to shit
in a bucket I mean she probably shits in
a pan right now but not in a bucket I
bet you George HW Bush does too the
former president yeah who's been accused
of sexual harassment poor guy poor guy
yeah well wait why is he the poor guy
he's old what what is that supposed to
mean I mean he can't you know it can't
be held accountable for his for grabbing
high knees
yeah are you saying that he should get a
free pass because he's old yes I think
it's even grosser when it's a whole guy
it's definitely more upsetting let's see
this lady said she saw the president's
get in the car yeah she got a chance to
meet him four years ago okay he's 93 so
he was 89 spry 89 89 years old he
sexually assaulted me he didn't shake
when he touched me from behind from his
wheelchair
with his wife Barbara by his side told
me a dirty joke mm-hmm all the while
being photographed touched me again oh
my god yeah
see I think it's it's wrong just because
it's so gross to be touched by that dude
how creepy is that
well would you want to get your about
squeezed by him would I I wouldn't mind
I really wouldn't mind and I wouldn't
mind if an 89 year old woman like she
was at your aunt's house how does a
pizza I go sure I stood by her
wheelchair and she went like oh and she
squeezed my hiney
and she was like a buzzy a stiff cock
and I'd be like okay I would be like
that was crazy this old lady in a
wheelchair just squeezed my ass and and
and said something dirty to me poor I
think it's even more appalling when was
it more than creepy because they're old
people are gross and creepy like old old
I do anything like a I'm scared of death
I'm scared of catching their death
honestly no I get that that's the
uncomfortable feeling of being around
the old but I'm saying for somebody
doing something like let's say let's say
let's just say what this scenario can
happen to you a guy can go like hey I
see you brought the whole about the milk
machine with you today yeah you know I
brought my coffee I see you brought the
milk brandy and then he put a line up he
puts his cup in front of your tits and
he's like can I get half and half from
this one and skim from that one mm-hmm
like that so is it create is it worse
that a 40 year old man does that six
year old man or a 90 year old man I
think it's worse at the 90 year old
because they're supposed to be sweet and
old and asexual when you're 90 it's
supposed to kind of whittle away but
isn't it less threatening I don't know I
know that it's gross it's grosser the
older they are it's gross but I mean
Brandon but the 40 or 50 or 60 year old
guy can actually like do something
in other words like this guy's in a
wheelchair he's like I remember when I
saw tits like that and he you know like
he can bear that's but that's why it's
even creepier and gross
like yanking so you would think worse
about that really yeah the old guy yes I
would honestly because they don't expect
it as much from the older guy the
younger guy you expecting to be creeps
so you're like I saw that one coming I
feel like when it's the older person
it's really it really catches you
off-guard when they're creepy you want
to hear the statement now go it's kind
of funny okay okay so they issued a
statement
his spokesman President Bush would never
under any circumstance intentionally
cause distress anyone he and sincerely
apologizes if his attempt at humor
offended this person and then that this
is what the the next statement said at
age 93 President Bush has been confined
to a wheelchair for roughly five years
his arm falls on the lower waist of
people can whom he takes pictures to try
to put people at ease the president
routinely tells the same joke and on
occasion he has padded women's rears and
what he intended to be a good-natured
manner some have seen as innocent others
clearly viewed as inappropriate to
anyone he has offended the president
sincerely apologizes oh he can't control
his his arm that's what so then well
then don't fucking take pictures of
people on that side of you well you
can't he can't they're saying that his
arm it can't control it so then he comes
up with a stock line and good life and
like my cock or something yeah I think
this might even be the picture hilarious
so like his left arm is probably like
around her ass right now or near it you
know I mean right he's like I wanna fuck
you or I don't know what he's saying but
he's probably like why Paul the way you
my father way to the top you wipe front
to back huh and that you think so I
don't think so babe do you wipe down
looks like I'm sorry can I tell you what
always bothers me about gross old dudes
and especially in wheelchairs I always
look at their crotches yeah and how
mushy yeah yeah like does your dick of
balls do they do they spread the older
you get yeah and everything everything's
hanging don't forget they're like
everything every
of skin everything you see his face is
drooping yeah I mean look at her
shoulders her tits are flat yeah yeah
yeah yeah your body's decaying yeah like
I think when Fitzsimmons it was like you
don't know if his dicks big or that's
just like skin just fallen over skin all
right yeah you know I am you know I bet
her nightmare to grow old her looks
can't be in good shape either well I've
seen I told you I had to change a
hundred year old lady for her birthday
party and her labia hung out hung
outside of her underwear I saw her labia
hang out and her tits were drooping out
of her bra - Jeff you like it around I
feel like if at a 90 year old man said
something like that to me I'd be like
Skyy okay so would you rather do the 90
year old guy they'll have to do him I'm
just talking about him saying we're
doing now but that's not what I'm would
you rather do the 90 year old guy or 16
Benadryl 'he's 16 benadryl so I have to
have sex with him but either/or it's 90
year old George or benadryl there's a
chance that I'd kill the guy yeah that's
somebody that's part of the would you
rather that's part of the thing you're
either risking your life for the a
lunatic to kill you or you're gonna
break his hips by buttfucking him yeah I
think it's eczema dad would do it you
but sex George yeah hilarious yeah add
that benadryl guys terrified I'm
watching mine hunter on Netflix right
now yeah he's in it someone like him is
in there yeah
slices of girls tits off I am NOT
interested in that shit in the least I
forget I was talking to I was like I am
NOT interested in any of these kinds of
shows yeah get woman getting their kids
their tits cut off and murderers and
shit I don't want to watch Hospital
stories I don't want to watch people
dying a cancer on one watch no fucking
white bummer movies I don't want to
watch black bummer movies I don't want
to watch any fucking bombers dude black
aids that fuck that shit what's that
movie now on the iTunes movie it's got
the everyone loves it it's a black guy
in the cover with like the light what's
I should call moon
my moonlight is not a bomber yeah oh
yeah it's a black see I'm not interested
in in the black aids bummer
it's fantastic yeah I just don't I can't
I don't have the emotional bandwidth I
cry at everything yeah I'm too sensitive
I know I know I know
man I feel too bad for people I am too
empathetic we keep that shit all day
yeah we keep putting it carry it because
we go see the you know the flowers or
the flan out with a session yeah and
about to shit my brother with me yeah I
love this shit smell that yeah she's got
the right here yeah it's part of the
experience like the experience part of
the experience grandma the experience
experience I want experience stuff I
smell my own shit no camping I don't
like that I love the lady that made this
too
she knew exactly what she was doing was
beautifully done what are we gonna do
when we're that old babe gonna die well
I mean who's gonna take care of us do we
just check ourselves into an old folks
home together
don't keep it's to keep us together
right oh yeah definitely I can't live
without you you're gonna die before me
though cuz men always do shit what the
fuck am I gonna do I don't know and I'm
older than you
babe do I have permission to get a
boyfriend in the retirement home um yeah
of course
of course you can get it you can get it
you can get a boyfriend there's no
closing song in my closing song file Oh
bitsy has a song for you come here
schnitzel you want to sing it's an empty
file
come here shit see god damn it come here
nothing in here your lips are singing
you a song dad okay send me a song
and beep I love your mom's house it's a
great show thank you for having me
everybody knows I'm a dog there you go
I love the show thank you for having me
on uh yeah no problem your mom's house
how about the Christina fuck-boy remix
oh sure yeah all right fat boy that's my
alley
yes sir yeah that's a fun one
all right this was a really fun hope you
guys enjoyed it see you on the next one
bye gene you Evan bye Jane I love you
love you too
I think fuck-boy is one of my favorite
like fun
[Music]
it's a huge ensign it's the pc version
of faggot what I like fuck boy if I
can't say faggot I'm gonna say fuck boy
fuck fuck it sounds like you're already
doing it fuck boy boy boy boy boy boy
boy boy boy it sounds like you're
already doing it
[Laughter]